今日はですね、お待たせしました
よっよっ
あのぉ～ずっと前から言ってたんですけども
あの謎の意味不明ゲーム
はじめ兄さんのアップデートがついに本日からスタートでございます
で、僕が実際にプレイして見せちゃってもあれなので
プレイの映像は見せないんですけども
まあ、何が変わったかと言いますと
まず一つ目
広告が少なくなりました
よっよっ
いやホントになんか
広告が多いっていう意見もあったんですけども
やっぱり、広告が無いとねアプリって成り立たないってところもあるので
けど、まあ極力減らすように色々工夫をした感じでございます
で、もう一つなんですけども
神まで辿り着いて終わったんですよね
アップデート前は
神まで辿り着いて終わったんですけども
神になった後の話
が、今回アップデートで増えてります
なんとですね
登場キャラクターが約２倍に増えていて
さらに
隠しはじめ兄さんも
なんというか、なんで笑ってんのｗ
隠しはじめ兄さんも何体か増えるということで
大きくねアプリ自体が進化したということで
一本道だった、レベル1,2,3,4,,5,6,7,8,9,10までいってこう
「何このワンパターン」
いや、けどやっぱ
不思議な世界観だからそこを楽しめることもあったと思うんですけど
さらに
それプラス、先の話も楽しめるってことでですね
まあ、今回色々とね深い要素までも
盛り込めたということでですね
是非ねはじめ兄さん
全く意味不明なゲームですけども
前よりかは遥かに深い話になっているので
よかったら、楽しんでいただけるとありがたいでございます
動画の説明欄からインストールできます
アップデート、もうインストールした方でもアップデートできます
Androidそしてios
全て対応しておりますので、よかったら是非ね
ダウンロードしてけろけろべす
じゃあな
～＾ED＾～